y
[Música]
los barcos ucranianos cargados con
granos en el puerto de dureza siguen a
la espera de luz verde para partir
cuando se haga efectivo el acuerdo
mediado por turquía y naciones unidas en
medio de la guerra entre tanto el
presidente excelentes que pidió a eeuu a
reconocer a rusia como un estado
patrocinador del terrorismo tras el
ataque a una cárcel en donges k
crece la presión sobre el gobierno de
francia ante pedidos opositores para
aumentar los impuestos a las compañías
energéticas
altamente beneficiadas por los aumentos
en los precios de la energía
consecuencia de la guerra en ucrania
emanuel macrón defiende que las
ganancias de las empresas son ganancias
para el pueblo francés
y el papá francisco regresa al vaticano
tras su llamada peregrinación de
penitencia a canadá donde pidió un
perdón histórico por el genocidio
cultural efectuado por la iglesia
católica que arrastró a miles de niños
indígenas a escuelas residenciales donde
fueron maltratados y abusados
una feliz mañana de sábado mi nombre es
ángela gómez y aquí están las noticias
desde france24 comenzamos en ucrania
donde continúa la expectativa por la
partida de los primeros barcos cargados
de cereales desde el puerto de odessa
esto una semana después de la firma de
un acuerdo mediado por turquía y por
naciones unidas entre las partes en
conflicto se estima que más de 20
millones de toneladas de granos se
encuentran bloqueados en los puertos
ucranianos como consecuencia de la
guerra ahora las embarcaciones esperan
la luz verde para zarpar los detalles
con nuestro enviado especial la de
catalina gómez ángel en la visita que
hizo ayer a la provincia dio des al
presidente volodomir sellent que
especialmente a uno de los tres puertos
habilitados para comenzar esa
exportación del grano los 20 millones de
toneladas que tiene en este momento
ucrania almacenadas en diferentes partes
del país dijo que todo estaba listo
desde el punto de vista logístico y
militar para que estas exportaciones
pudieran empezar a hacer realidad sin
embargo están a la espera de las
noticias que lleguen de ese centro de
coordinación que se abrió el pasado
miércoles en turquía y que estará
coordinado por las naciones unidas y que
coordina todo el proceso de exportación
del grano ellos también proveen esas
rutas seguras que deben seguir los
navíos sin embargo siguen en esa
coordinación con bosco y todavía no se
han definido exactamente cuáles serán
esos mecanismos específicos que deben
seguir estos barcos así que aquí están a
la espera de esa luz verde ellos habían
dicho que esperaban poder salir que el
primer barco saliera a finales de la
semana sin embargo estábamos a sábado
hay gente que todavía no cree que este
pacto puede hacerse realidad muchos no
confían en moscú sin embargo estamos a
la espera habían dado como plazo mañana
por lo menos el ministro de
infraestructura dijo que al final de la
semana así que en las próximas horas
deben haber algunas noticias el
presidente ucraniano volodymyr selenski
se pronunció después del ataque con
misiles en una prisión administrada por
separatistas pro rusos en la provincia
de donges que mató a más de 50
prisioneros de guerra ucranianos pidió
directamente a eeuu a reconocer a rusia
como un estado patrocinador del
terrorismo
schild um
fue un crimen de guerra ruso deliberado
el asesinato masivo deliberado de
prisioneros de guerra ucranianos más de
50 muertos cuando los defensores de asof
tal salían de la planta el comité
internacional de la cruz roja y la onu
se convirtieron en garantes de la vida y
la salud de nuestros guerreros ahora los
garantes deben proteger la vida de
cientos de prisioneros de guerra
ucranianos y agregaría por mi parte que
debería haber un claro reconocimiento
legal de rusia como patrocinador estatal
del terrorismo
en otras noticias el gobierno francés se
enfrenta a una creciente presión para
aumentar los impuestos sobre las grandes
empresas energéticas del país total y
angie impulsadas por el aumento de los
precios de la energía debido a la guerra
de rusia contra ucrania han registrado
beneficios récord
impulsado por la subida de los precios
de la energía los gigantes del gas y la
gasolina de francia han reportado
beneficios récord total energía se ha
reportado más de 10.000 millones de
euros en ganancias y en más de 5 mil
millones lo que ha provocado nuevas
peticiones de impuestos extraordinarios
ya que las facturas de los consumidores
siguen aumentando la asamblea nacional
rechazó la medida a pesar de la presión
de su oposición
en el panorama es normal que los
franceses paguen más para cubrir a los
accionistas no estoy en contra de que
las empresas obtengan beneficios pero
aprovecharse de una crisis es
intolerable
shane patria en toda europa algunos
países ya están obligando a pagar a los
gigantes de la energía italia introdujo
un impuesto del 25 por ciento sobre las
empresas una medida similar adoptada por
el reino unido- que impuso un impuesto
del 25 por ciento a los gigantes del
petróleo y el gas y españa también está
considerando un impuesto sobre los
beneficios que se extenderá a los bancos
mientras que la izquierda francesa lleva
meses presionando para que se aplique el
impuesto a las ganancias excesivas el
gobierno minoritario del presidente
manuel macro está presionando a las
empresas para que hagan sus propios
sacrificios para ayudar al consumidor
total ha reducido los precios de la
gasolina hasta finales de año y en ya ha
reembolsado 100 euros a los clientes que
reciben vales de energía 17 estoy
orgulloso de los resultados de nuestras
empresas francesas y sorprendido de ver
cómo se les echa la culpa hoy después de
que hayan obtenido buenos resultados
los buenos resultados de las empresas
francesas son buenos resultados para los
franceses
el ministro de economía bruno le maire
prefiere aumentar las ayudas a subir los
impuestos pero mientras el gobierno
minoritario se esfuerza por aliviar la
crisis del coste de la vida que se
agrava la oposición va a seguir
presionando
en irak los partidarios del clérigo
iraquí chiíta moqtada al-sadr volvieron
a asaltar hoy el parlamento en bagdad en
la continuación de las manifestaciones
multitudinarias contra el candidato pro
iraní a primer ministro mohamed decía al
sudaní los manifestantes se reunieron en
un puente en la capital y usaron cuerda
sea para derribar las secciones del muro
e invadieron la zona verde llena de
edificios gubernamentales y embajadas
desde las elecciones de octubre del 2021
se mantiene la parálisis política en
irak pues los legisladores siguen sin
ponerse de acuerdo sobre la conformación
de un gobierno se espera que el
parlamento vote mañana para elegir un
nuevo presidente
el ejército nigeriano anunció este
viernes que encontró este mes a tres
niñas de chivo un grupo de 276 jóvenes
entre los 12 y los 19 años que habían
sido secuestrados en 2014 por el grupo
yihadista boko haram el caso conmovió al
mundo oyente entero y dio lugar a la
campaña en redes sociales denominada
bring back a workers
caminaron dos días para liberarse de
ocho años de secuestro a guayana to
hacen parte de las niñas de chivos
estudiantes secuestradas en 2014 por
bucarám en el norte de nigeria el
viernes el ejército les presentó a la
prensa junto a ruth de 24 años que
encontraron hace unos días con su hijo
de 2 años tres de las niñas de chivo que
están aquí con ustedes
la niña son
rubitos agua nunca y en átomos como son
desde 2014 de las 276 niñas de chivo
algunas lograron escapar otras han sido
intercambiadas por comandantes del grupo
yihadista en negociaciones con las
autoridades pero más de 100 siguen
desaparecidas actualmente en abril a
cumplir ocho años desde el secuestro
amnistía internacional acusó a las
autoridades nigerianas de incumplir su
deber de proteger a los niños ya que
según la ong más de 1500 estudiantes han
sido secuestrados en nigeria desde el
drama de chivo que las autoridades se
han mostrado muy reacias tanto
investigar estos ataques como exigir
responsabilidades a los autores de estos
crímenes atroces cada nuevo ataque va
acompañado de nuevos secuestros que
privan a los jóvenes de su derecho a la
libertad y dejan a las familias de las
víctimas sin esperanza de acceder a la
justicia la verdad o la reparación
en el noreste de nigeria la insurgencia
yihadista lleva 13 años un conflicto
interno que mató a 40.000 personas y
desplazó a más de 2 millones
y el papá francisco terminó su viaje a
canadá y partió rumbo a roma tras pedir
perdón a las comunidades indígenas por
el genocidio cultural de la iglesia en
las antiguas escuelas donde miles de
niños fueron violentados hasta la muerte
respondiendo a un periodista local el
papá reiteró su disculpa histórica por
arrancar los de sus familias e intentar
cambiar su cultura entre 1881 y
1996 más de 150.000 niños fueron
llevados a las instituciones muchos
murieron de hambre fueron golpeados y
abusados sexualmente
ok y esto
excusa perdono
pero puesto laboró es cierto que no use
la palabra porque no pensé en ella pero
describió un genocidio pedí perdón pedí
perdón por este trabajo que fue un
genocidio condene esto tolere bambini
cambiar arrebatar niños e intentar
cambiar su cultura sus mentes cambiar
sus tradiciones raza y toda una cultura
si genocidio es una palabra técnica pero
no la use porque no lo pensé pero la
describí si es un genocidio sí sí claro
puedes decir que yo dije que fue un sant
cine no me menos demente
descrito que pero si es un sitio
ya volvemos con más siguen france24
[Música]